1 et qui vend mon jour merci d'être avec
nous bonjour monsieur thibault ils vont
injecter la teneur des discussions hier
sur le parquet de la convention
moderniser la souveraineté ça veut dire
quoi moderniser la survente est pour
vous ça veut dire partir des
préoccupations des gens et de partir
deux pour établir un dialogue et montrer
comment la souveraineté peut être la
réponse aux défis qui les préoccupe pour
défi qui nous préoccupent comme
québécois que l'on pense à la crise
climatique la lutte aux inégalités la
question évidemment du rayonnement notre
langue notre culture puis d'une
démocratie plus saines avec moins de
cynisme donc ce sont quatre grands défis
qui sont clairement établies dans notre
déclaration principe notre déclaration
de refondation et on démontrait bien
comment l'indépendance est un fil
conducteur pour répondre à ces
préoccupations le donc plutôt que de
partir de l'indépendance comme mon
espèce d'idéal désincarné on veut
vraiment montrer comment l'indépendance
est incarnée dans les défis
d'aujourd'hui dans la modernité du
québec d'aujourd'hui
on dirait que les gens sont davantage
attirés vers la notion de nationalisme
quand on regarde la façon les programmes
politiques et ce qui semble attirer des
lecteurs québécois
comment vous faites pour passer par
dessus ça et convaincre les gens qu'ils
souveraineté c'est encore quelque chose
qui devrait être au goût du jour mais
parce que pour nous l'indépendance est
justement l'aboutissement logique du
nationalisme si on veut se battre pour
la nation québécoise si on veut se
battre pour ce qui la distingue ceux qui
la forge
mais il faut avoir tous les moyens de
nos ambitions pour pouvoir répondre à ce
qui nous importe aux défis qui nous
importe à notre manière à nous alors
c'est pour ça que c'est on le dit
d'ailleurs celle des des valeurs qu'on
met de l'avant
à quel point c'est l'aboutissement
logique donc je pense que par exemple
quand on voit l'adhésion des québécois a
des idées
nationaliste c'est de dire mais pourquoi
on s'arrêterait a essayé de se battre
pour aller au bout de nos ambitions dans
un cadre qui nous qui nous contraint
donc on veut pouvoir relever tous les
défis qui nous importe avec tous nos
moyens c'est tout si ça que ça s'appelle
l'indépendance du québec
vous avez traversé une période
électorale et dernière particulièrement
difficile et il a un an plus tard il ya
de l'eau québécois qui lui à ottawa koné
connaît un regain de popularité à quel
point ce que ça vient changer la donne
dans vos discussions ce mouvement là
cette semaine mais c'est sûr que je
pense que c'est c'est porteur d'espoir
on l'a vu on l'a vu hier les gens sont
très heureux de cette victoire lé
d'indépendantistes donc de députés qui
sont indépendantiste est de montrer que
oui les québécois voient encore cette
valeur d'avoir leur voix propre d'avoir
une voie propre pour le québec
puis si on veut pousser cette logique là
cette voie le elle doit elle devrait se
transporter poche juste au québec pour
juste à ottawa mais sur la scène
internationale c'est aussi c'est un
enjeu très contemporain
quand on voit toutes les nations qui se
réunissent de plus en plus dans les
forums supranationaux de dire que le
québec a quelque chose à apporter au
monde le savoy propre à apporter au
monde aussi donc c'est sûr que c'est
porteur d'espoir mais on va aller
beaucoup plus loin
qu'est ce que les électeurs québécois
ont vraiment voté pour au port pour
l'indépendance ou sait pas davantage ce
qui était perçue par les commentateurs
comme un vote de protestation à l'égard
des autres partis le bloc et elle évoque
est allé au bloc québécois
je pense que vraiment toutes sortes de
raisons qui font que les gens ont voté
pour le bloc québécois
certains bien sûr parce que ce sont des
députés indépendantistes d'autres parce
qu'il jugeait que c'était important de
porter une voix forte pour le québec
d'autres aussi parce qu'ils veulent
montrer qu'ils sont insatisfaits des
partis fédéralistes et comme le dit très
bien
monsieur blanchet même quand il ya des
gens qui ne sont pas souverainiste qui
viennent vers des gens qui porte cet
idéal
c'est une manière d'incarner dialogue de
le faire vivre
je suis très fier parce qu au parti
québécois on est vraiment dans cette
logique là parce qu'au delà de notre
déclaration de principe
on revoit complètement nos manières de
faire puis je pense que le parti
québécois va montrer au sortir de la fin
de semaine qu'on est en train vraiment
de moderniser pas juste nos manières de
faire au parti québécois mais de comment
faire la politique en s'ouvrant à des
gens de l'extérieur en tendant la main
pour que ces gens là viennent discuter
avec nous en retournant sur le terrain
c'est des choses fondamentales pour la
suite comporte un projet comme
indépendant dites moi qu'est ce que vous
avez vu dans la recette mais appliquée
par le bloc québécois qui pourrait
fonctionner pour vous des prêts mais je
pense beaucoup de beaucoup d'humilité
prendre acte des des défis qui sont les
noms de postes mettre la tête dans le
sable donc de partir avec des attentes
modéré mais avec de l'ambition en même
temps donc d'être dans un dialogue très
ouvert avec la population d'aller à la
rencontre de la population de partir
d'eux sans prétention et en allant
chercher une équipe de gens prêtent des
gens et ça c'est une clé très importante
donc je pense qu'il ya beaucoup de
leçons et nous ça fait des mois parti
québécois qu'avec des centaines de
bénévoles une équipe qui représente
l'alliance des générations au sein de
notre conseil exécutif on a travaillé
très fort pour cette refondation le
petit se met en branle aujourd'hui et je
pense qu'il ya beaucoup d'inspiration
tirer de ce cas on est capable d'allier
l'ambition avec jeudi vous dirai aussi
une certaine forme de modestie et de
prise de contact avec la réalité des
défis que sont les notes devant nous
parce que ce n'est que le début du du
recommencement et on sait qu'on l'a
beaucoup de travail devant nous l'année
dernière juste après l'élection j'étais
parlez vous et moi
vous étiez déçu évidemment du résultat
un an plus tard avez vous l'impression
d'être enduit là où vous deviez être
dans votre tête à peu près oui je dois
vous dire que c'est beaucoup de travail
qui s'est fait dans l'ombre alors les
gens ne mesurent pas toujours à quel
point il ya du travail qui a été abattu
mais j'ai dit très rapidement dans les
jours qui ont suivi elle à la défaite du
1er octobre à quel point il fallait se
concentrer d'abord sur le quoi sur
l'essence de ce que nous sommes
parce que je pense que c'est ce que de
plus important d'être clair d'être
transparent que les québécois pour
regagner la confiance envers notre
formation politique sache exactement où
on loge ce qu'on veut leur offrir
et donc pour moi c'était fondamental
très heureuse que ce soit la proche
qu'on a pris 2 vraiment focus et sur le
quoi les sens la déclaration de principe
et ensuite de s'en aller vers les autres
étapes du chi de la chefferie de
l'éventuelle détails d'un programme je
pense que le sur deux pages aussi c'est
quoi le parti québécois nos valeurs nos
principes nos défis et l'indépendance
qui est le fil conducteur puisque
extraordinaire manière de retourner vers
les québécois et vous l'impression est
ce que c'est le congrès de la dernière
chance pour le pq cet exercice là je
voudrais que c'est le congrès de la
chance renouvelée et on veut passer on
veut pas se fier sur la chanson veut se
fier sur le travail puis moi aujourd'hui
j'ai une certaine émotion parce que je
sais ce qu'on a traversé depuis un an je
sais comment les gens se sont retroussé
les manches pour dire on a quelque chose
qui est très fort à offrir aux québécois
il faut trouver les moyens de rebâtir ce
dialogue le parce que pour toute nation
c'est normal d'avoir un projet
d'indépendance de vouloir avoir tous ces
leviers entre ses mains donc pour moi
c'est le recommencement aujourd'hui
après avoir traversé oui des mois qui
ont été très très chargé rempli de défis
pour mettre les choses positivement mais
aujourd'hui c'est ce concert un
enthousiasme renouvelé un niveau on
parle beaucoup de chez free sur le
parquet de la convention du congrès ait
encore beaucoup de gens qui évoque votre
nom je sais que vous avez mis de côté
cette idée l'année dernière
sk qui ont réussi ou qui commencent à
vous faire réfléchir à la chose
peut-être vous faire changer d'idée
écouté beaucoup de gens qui m'en ont
parlé avant pendant après mais la
décision elle et elle est très claire
elle est très ferme c'est juste
incompatible avec avec ma situation
personnelle familiale alors à l'heure
actuelle donc j'apprécie beaucoup les
tapes dans le dos les votes de confiance
mais ce qui est important c'est que moi
je vais rester là très active à
dialoguer avec vous à chaque fois vous
allez vouloir encore très présente avec
les membres et les gens qui
s'intéressent à nos idées mais ce sera
pas dans une fonction de chief et il ya
toutes sortes de rôles à jouer dans un
parti je vais continuer à jouer tous les
rôles que je vais pouvoir jouer c'est
juste pas compatibles ce niveau
d'intensité en ce moment avec ma vie
c'est aussi simple que ça véronique
hivon merci beaucoup merci beaucoup de
votre intérêt